so etwas geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video ich hoffe natürlich
euch jedes gut der ein oder andere von
euch weiß eventuell ich habe vor einiger
zeit bei zum rtl-format mitgemacht die
retouren profis haben wir mal so
palettenweise ware gekauft und dann
weiterverkauft habe ich dann unter
anderem auch moore kennen gelernt das
ist so ein großhändler hier bei mir
sogar in der nähe und er hat ganz ganz
viele retouren und waren und alles
mögliche ich habe mich letzte woche mal
mit ihm getroffen und habe mir gedacht
er passt auf was wäre interessant wenn
man youtube channel für euch als
zuschauer was gibt es noch nicht was
kann ich ihm abkaufen und ausparken an
euch zu zeigen dass es sowas gibt und da
kommen jetzt zalando und spielen kennt
wahrscheinlich jeder von euch so weit
ich weiß ist der retouren passant an
zalando sogar kostenlos und 50 prozent
aller bestellten ware wird
zurückgeschickt das ist ja
geisteskranken schlecht für zalando gut
für mich vielleicht hoffen wir's mal
gekauft habe ich mir folgendes ich habe
es nicht mit gefilmt gegen die habe ich
in dem moment da nicht dran gedacht zu
kartons ich kannst dich immer ein
blendend mit alando war ich weiß nicht
wie viel da drin ist da kann alles drin
sein weil alles wirklich nur von zalando
und ich hoffe mal auf keine ware weil
ich habe insgesamt ungefähr wirklich
nicht viel für alles zusammen etwas mehr
als 100 euro bezahlt gute preis an kino
kommt ja noch mal wieder und wir schauen
uns jetzt mal an was wir finden hallo
ich bin's der retouren profi übrigens in
dieser perspektive wir uns ganz lange
schon nicht mehr gesehen fällt mir
gerade ein aber das liegt einfach daran
weil ich schon so lange keine geilen
sachen mehr ausgepackt habe ja irgendwie
habe ich da nicht mehr so bock drauf
gehabt aber ihr könnt sehen es ist was
neues angekommen ich habe jetzt hier bei
mir im büro 8 paket von zalando also
wirklich das sind originale der landung
retouren ich habe keine ahnung warum wir
irgendwas von outlet punkt ms draufsteht
was ist das eigentlich sollte ich mal
nachschauen sollen nicht mal aufgeräumt
heute hier damit man sich die knie
schont auf jeden fall bin ich jetzt mal
gespannt was da drin ist wie gesagt da
kann alles drin sollen schuhe klamotten
glaube dann hört es bei zalando auch auf
wobei man da mittlerweile auch viel mehr
bestellen kann soweit ich weiß ich habe
tatsächlich für diese acht kartons nur
knapp über 100 euro bezahlt also geht
voll das heißt wenn wir einmal irgendwo
einen geilen schulen haben haben wir das
theoretisch schon wieder raus aber das
muss man erst mal klappen let's go
12 3 4 5 6 7 8 und mit dem fangen wir an
aber ich habe bock leute endlich mal
wieder was auspacken okay leute also ich
muss sagen erst paket ist halt leider
nicht schwer deswegen denke ich nicht
dass der schule drin sind aber wer weiß
vielleicht ja geil adresse
12 wir haben hier einmal die das t shirt
nähen adidas tanktop ja das ist wirklich
so ein pumper dinge welche größe ist
dort m oder ist das für frauen die das
ist so fürs fitnessstudio würde ich
behaupten das kann ich eigentlich sogar
direkt selber behalten auch wenn ich
nicht so oft ins fitnessstudio gehe
trotzdem der sommer kommt ja bald war
das feuer ich schon muss ich sagen ist
schon getragen gewesen komplett neu das
ist ein jackett würde ich mal sagen das
hat bestimmt schon wert oder hier stets
doch paul smith jackett in blau da steht
doch kein alter sein jackett das ist
doch schon das cost bestimmt 50 euro
halter war das ist ein richtiges
designer teil die kosten hier parkt 795
euro also halten nicht länger das werde
ich mir direkt mal über brocken ja ich
weiss es passt sich so zu meinem hemd
heute aber
junge wer bist du denn ich habe hier ein
spiegel ich muss sagen das ist mir
leider ganz bisschen zu eng aber für
dieses unboxing-video heute schade vor
drei jahren mit meinem internet business
angefangen weil ich einfach keine lust
mehr hatte am fließband zu stehen und
nun nach drei jahren habe ich es
geschafft meine viele produkte
erfolgreich zu skalieren und wenn du das
auch schaffen möchtest dann klickt
einfach auf den link und downloaded die
rmh ein kostenloses programm es ist
wirklich kostenlos einmalig nur 40
plätze er so komme ich mir vor oder das
könnte schon ganz gut hinkommen wenn das
so schon anfängt und dieses ding mir das
ist wirklich also ich finde hier kein
jackett von hinte unter 200 euro dann
will ich gar nicht wissen was er meist
der pakete drin ist das ist das thema 7
700 ist das vielleicht gefälscht nein
765 euro kostet das hier das kann ja
nicht wahr sind also ich muss natürlich
auch erst mal verkauft bekommen wenn ich
nicht selber behalte aber das ist schon
geil weitergeht
so schauen wir mal was im nächsten paket
drin ist einmal und einmal muster das
sieht mir nach einem schuhkarton aus wir
haben hier einmal schuhe würde mal sagen
das sind frauen schuhe und noch so ein
ding das shirt von weekday auf eine
marke die man sicherlich kennt man hier
stehen sogar noch preise dran oder
stehen die preise von dxs original
katanha gut wenn ich persönlich nichts
mit anfangen ist bauchfrei aber für die
ladies warum nicht ich glaube das war
dann wahrscheinlich eine frauen
bestellung haben wir hier noch zwei
letzten von vero moda auch nicht
schlecht hier so sind die aus vero moda
ist sicherlich auch eine marke die man
kennt und hier ist auch direkt das
preisschild mit 344 euro 99 dafür auch
nicht verkehrt und komplett neu man kann
es ja sehr schön eingepackt die tun wir
mal schnell wieder rein größte 39 die
kann ich eigentlich wirklich meiner mama
schenken ich weiß noch nicht ob ich so
was rockt gut
lobt mama direkt weiter hier mit dem
nächsten schritt sagt wir haben hier ein
hemd ist okay leute und ein schal hier
auch save gute qualität merke ich jetzt
schon ein schickes hemdchen und dann
noch diesen charme
alter das kann aber doch nicht sein nach
nevada war das ist kein schal das ist so
eine rose für frauen gebt euch das nur
die kostet einfach
299 euro 95 diese hose und ich habe also
unter uns mal ich habe pro paket ist
auch gleich kleiner freundschaftspreis
gewesen 15 euro bezahlt und hier immer
noch ein hemd von fresko will karl j das
behalte ich mega geil und wenn ich muss
mal kurz umziehen also hierzu muss ich
jetzt sagen steht mir finde ich nicht so
gut aber ist in ordnung das hat keinen
besonders großen berg wir machen weiter
mit dem nächsten paket sagte zapp zarap
damenschuhe glaube ich von aldo nicht
von aldi sondern also hier noch so eine
bluse nichts besonderes ich komme mir
ein bisschen vor wie bei den koffer
unboxing nur dass die sachen halt besser
sind und auch deutlich teurer wenn ich
jetzt nicht so interessant und
handschuhe drin personage naldo wird
kosten die steht nichts dran in größe 37
würde ich mal auch so ähnlich wie die
vero moda schlappen bei 40 euro
einordnen kommen wir wieder schnell
zurück neues paket neues glück ist das
denn entweder es gibt aber auch sachen
wer trägt denn so was das ist ein kleid
trug mal leute für 60 euro oder ist das
ein alter deshalb ein riesenrad das ist
im rock kann man sich so glaube ich ganz
gut an mir vorstellen dann kann ich
direkt aufs nächste mittelalterfest
gehen also das wäre jetzt nichts für
mich und ich würde das auch keinem
empfehlen und hier haben wir dann noch
von adidas wieder ein tanktop auch
eigentlich geil ist würde ich mal sagen
für kinder oder für kleinere menschen in
es ich muss sagen ich hätte jetzt gerne
aber nochmal ein bäcker die ist eine
jackett ohne scheiß dieses tor cap ist
einfach das siebenfache wert wie der
preis den ich für alle sachen zusammen
bezahlt haben muss man sich mal
vorstellen und hier haben wir so sieht
das aus eine hose ach so ich dachte dass
das dann ist das für männer ohne
sommerhose dann haben wir noch eine
große war das sind wirklich gute hosen
ey leute krank von viktor & rolf ich
glaube die sind mir leider ein bisschen
zu groß und dann haben wir hier noch da
müssen jetzt eigentlich mal so schöne
männerschuhe drin sein von gino
armes oder ach quatsch die sind nicht
kaputt ich dachte die wären kaputt auch
komplett neu auch die haben kranke
qualität das muss ich sagen bin mutter
shorts vega einfach diese hose kostet
bei zalando 136 euro und diese hier 100
euro keine ahnung ich weiß um ehrlich zu
sein noch gar nicht wie ich die sachen
wieder los werden soll weil meinen shop
gibt es ja nicht mehr vielleicht muss
ich das über ebay verkaufen oder so
keine ahnung schuhe 70 euro wenn du dass
dies gibt mir bitte noch mehr von diesen
paketen ja ich brauche die dann kriegt
was haben wir hier okay das sieht mir
eigentlich nach willigen jeans aus misst
sie wird mir zu klein sein wir haben
eine hose alter was hab ich denn hier
etf und noch eine hose und jetzt passt
mal auf ich habe gerade was gesehen kann
doch nicht sein was habe ich denn da
gekauft diese rose die es mir auch zu
obwohl die können mir sogar passen ich
probiere gern mal eben an für euch ist
das muss ich neben der kamera machen
weil ich habe nämlich keine unterhose
unter meiner jogginghose heute weil ich
hatte keine frische unterhose mehr leute
schaut mal was für ein frisches outfit
auch gerade mit der uhr und so dazu es
sieht doch einfach geil aus und das habe
ich aus diesen paketen raus
mega topware so krasse ware hatte ich
noch nie noch nie in irgend einem
unboxing von mir also und diese hose die
war da auch noch drin und jetzt schaut
euch das mal an das kann ja fast nicht
glauben hier steht ich habe mich
verlesen hatte gerade 600 euro auf 190
euro für die hose ist von global frank
renmark das ist wirklich eine gute marke
aber leider werden wir die viel zu engen
und dann haben wir hier noch das letzte
paket das beste kommt immer zum schluss
123 und hier ist nur ein schuhkarton
drin kombiniert aber bitte mal
herrenschuhe herrenschuhe glaube ich
zumindest pier one größe 42 hassen auch
heute sogar zu meinem outfit ich habe 43
jahren passt da nicht rein
zack jawohl geht doch ja leute check
mein outfit was meint ihr so kann man
sich doch blicken lassen oder also ich
muss wirklich sagen geile sachen dabei
wir hatten richtig richtig geile sachen
bei super ich werde deshalb noch mal
bestellen leute hier sieht jetzt zwar
alles ein bisschen chaotisch aus aber
man muss ja sagen es hat sich so was von
gelohnt mega ich habe ja an sich für
alles zusammen 100 euro bezahlt oder so
und wir haben keine ahnung wir haben
bestimmt dass fast das zwanzigfache
rausgeholt geisteskrank leute lassen nur
nach oben da wenn ich weitere zalando
paket bestellen sollen in den nächsten
tagen wird auch schon das nächste
unboxing video folgen ich hab echt gute
amazon bestellt deswegen takkt ag marijn
abonniert super g den kanal und wir
sehen uns die tage wieder leute haut
rein